[Music]
historic event last night did you see
this last night nasa broadcast live
footage of their rover making its
dramatic landing on
mars incredible
[Applause]
unbelievable
yeah
then uh eight hours later nbc showed it
yeah
like
what a
promos for
did you watch it last night anyway i did
watch it i did watch it and then i
thought about oh my god there must be so
much nerd sex happening tonight
trust me there was
[Music]
no that was a pretty risky mission it
was so risky nasa scientists dubbed
seven minutes of terror that's what they
called that mission seven minutes of
terror
yeah nasa scientists named the mission
after the time a woman tried to talk to
them in the hallway
[Music]
make it go away
[Music]
make him joey
the hell was that wow
what am i saying that for
brilliant engineers made this amazing
thing happen let's see conan's take
[Music]
[Laughter]
good
girls
everyone's still talking about michael
phelps he's the man of the hour michael
phelps you're one of the greatest of all
time
come on what does that happen
medals
this is the impression just with all the
medals that's it that's all i got
now uh during an interview with the wall
street journal do you hear this michael
phelps said everybody pees in the pool
yeah
yeah then he dropped his pants and said
but only a champion pees during an
interview with the wall street journal
no one saw that coming
you see this an american judo fighter
was expelled from the olympics after
testing positive for marijuana
yeah yeah officials became suspicious
they became suspicious when he kept
stopping the match and saying what are
we fighting for man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and as a scientist was there
listen to this one gang
gather round everybody
mitt romney is claiming he's going to
create 12 million jobs in his first term
yeah however
romney hasn't said yet whether he'll
create those jobs in china or india he's
not sure
he's still thinking
he's here
we're here
someone over here was booing 12 million
new jobs
who needs jobs man
it's the judo champion over here
whatever man
job shmob
a new ad from the obama campaign claims
that mitt romney is out of touch when it
comes to women's issues
yeah today mitt romney said i'm not out
of touch with women's issues just ask my
wife mrs mitt romney
it's insensitive to use his name for
hers
[Applause]
and i'm back over here
i don't know what's going on yeah you
that was your perfect chance to go away
forever yeah
you better have taken it
you just you just see me getting a
little boat back there
a tiny little coating yeah
one joke kind of didn't and then just in
the boat
i'm gone forever